hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to another code
review the series in which you guys send
me your code and projects and all that
stuff and i take a look at it so last
time we were on linux taking a look at a
voxel rendering kind of engine so check
out that video i'll have it linked up
there if you wanted to catch up with
this series today we're taking a look at
something that i think is going to be
really interesting to a lot of people
and we're back on windows
yes what's this your computer will
restart so this time around we have maka
iwashko saying that your series about
hazel engine motivated me to finally do
my own engine as well it's a software
ray tracing engine supporting reflection
refraction area lights soft shadows
polygon mesh rendering so i would be
very grateful for a code review there is
also an informative read me with
pictures in the repository and here is
linked repository as always i will have
that link in the description below in
case you guys also wanted to check it
out now i thought this would be kind of
interesting because whilst we have
looked at engines in the past we really
haven't looked at any ray tracing
engines and for those of you who don't
know
ray traces typically do not run in real
time and especially not a software ray
tracing engine so software ray tracing
means that it's done on the cpu not on
what we call hardware which i mean a cpu
is also like a piece of hardware but
hardware usually refers to gpu or the
graphics processing unit so your
graphics card this on the other hand is
a software ray tracing engine which kind
of makes it seem like it is in fact done
from scratch a lot of people don't
really perceive hardware programming as
a from scratch because you're usually
using like a graphics api like vulcan or
opengl or directx whereas if you do
things on the cpu you're typically just
programming basically just like
mathematical equations that contribute
to a pixel kind of array which to a lot
of people is kind of a lot more bare
bones there's no kind of worrying about
what the graphics card is doing or
having to use their apis you can kind of
more or less focus on the actual
algorithms and the mathematics behind
that stuff instead of worrying about an
api like vulcan or opengl that's if you
compare it to something like doing this
in a compute shader in vulcan where you
would have to worry about like where the
computer fits into the pipeline how to
get data to the compute shader how to
then get that texture and render it as
part of like a graphics pass so you can
see it on the screen it's like a whole
thing right so this is definitely going
to be a lot more simple and to the point
which is something that i like to see
now let's quickly like i'm just going to
gloss through this i'm going to read
this in front of you guys again the link
to this is in the description below if
you want to read everything it's written
fully in cbs plus 17 which is
interesting looks like cmake is
important however actually if you're
using visual studio it looks like it
does in fact include a solution file so
we'll just be able to open it in that
and uh yeah it looks pretty cool so
let's take a look at this in more detail
wow he's actually got a pretty decent
like readme
this is this is looking up this is
looking looking good but before we jump
in and take a look at this project i
want to thank skillshare for sponsoring
this video for those of you who don't
know skillshare is an amazing online
learning community where millions of
creative and curious people from all
around the world can come together into
a community and learn new skills by
taking
taking a class on almost anything
imaginable whether you're interested in
photography videography animation
illustration marketing business stuff
productivity they literally have
everything on their platform and all of
their classes are incredibly high
quality concise to the point no fluff no
churno style videos no just just you
know just good videos they don't have to
worry about youtube and the algorithm
and likes and comments and don't forget
to subscribe no their videos are
actually
perfect for learning i've been using
skillshare here and there for little
things that i've wanted to learn such as
concept art for an upcoming game i may
or may not be working on and other
things as well such as youtube and how
to make better videos if you would like
to check out skillshare you're in luck
because skillshare is offering the first
1000 people who click the link in the
description a one month free trial of
skillshare premium so you can check out
literally all of their classes for a
month and see if there's anything there
that you like so definitely click the
link in the description below there's no
reason not to check them out huge thank
you as always to skillshare for
sponsoring this video so what i've done
here is i've cloned the repository just
a little quick tip
whenever i clone i tend to clone
recursively just in case there are like
git sub modules that i also need to
fetch looks like there weren't any in
this repository but just a little tip
because i've seen a lot of people not
clone recursively and then wonder why
things don't work out of the box that's
that's the reason that it might not work
now speaking of working out of the box
last time i had to fix the project so
let's see how good this goes and i i
vowed that if someone was to send me a
project that didn't work again i would
be extremely upset so let's go ahead and
try and build this see if it builds
let's find the main file
and uh looking good so far
um
all right guys let's let's let's bring
it in let's bring it in this is about to
become a tutorial on
files and working directories because i
see this way too much one of the biggest
problems when learning programming and i
i used to do this this is also a
personal story about what i was like
back in the day people just seem to
struggle with files loading files like
if i want to load a file in java or c
plus plus or some other programming
language like how do i load the file if
i don't use some kind of absolute path
what is it relative to i have no idea
why like this doesn't seem to
specifically be taught i'm pretty sure i
was never really taught about the
concept of a working directory but
let's let's dive into this so the first
thing is obviously for those of you who
don't know
this is a problem because this is
something we call an absolute path
absolute path because it kind of begins
from the root
right this begins from the d drive and
then it goes into the dev directory and
then cg and ray tracing the thing is i
do have a d drive but i and i do have a
default this is all very suspicious but
i do not have a directory called cg and
this is certainly not the directory of
this file does not exist on on my
computer on the person who
who actually wrote this presumably it
does but the bigger problem is there's
no actual reason to ever write code like
this in fact absolute parts are
something you absolutely want to avoid
in certain situations they may be
required because you might have certain
files on your computer in different
places usually you would maybe set an
environment variable and then required
to kind of access that environment
variable if you need to like get a path
of something else on your computer
that's kind of specialist cases for the
most part there's no reason for this
part to be here we need to be able to
open this file in a more relative sense
so when i write some c plus plus code to
open a file how do i create a relative
path like what is that path relative to
well to understand that you need to
understand something called the working
directory in visual studio if we right
click on the project and go to
properties and then debugging you can
see we have this thing called a working
directory under the debugging properties
this is currently set to
a macro or a variable called project der
now what that is what that macro is is
the actual location of this project file
on disk this vcx proj because that's our
ray tracing project file that directory
so in this case c dev youtube code
review ray tracing that is what this is
right and if you have any doubt as to
what this is you can of course edit it
and see what the macro expands to in
fact you can see what all of the macros
expand to so if you wanted to know what
the solution directory was in this case
it's the same you can see the value of
that macro here very important stuff so
that means that when i run this through
visual studio
right in this case the debug
configuration on the x64 platform right
i mean this will be the same for all
configurations the point is it will set
the working directory to be that project
directory so if i open up that directory
again you can see that
this is now my relative kind of root so
if i then just go input slash you know
shotgun.scene right which in this case
would just look like
this or i could use
or i could use forward slashes and
instead of backslashes and i guess
forward slash is what i mean this is
also technically a maybe a slightly
better way to write this because for
slashes work on all platforms i'm
actually not sure depending on what
simple sports api you use it might
actually work even on like linux if you
do this or on mac but it for a more
portable way you always want to use
forward slashes with like file paths so
this path now is in fact going to work
because again our working directory is
this and if you pass in this actual path
you don't modify it at all into like you
know std if stream or something like
file
and then you do like you know fopen
right
if open then it's that's going to work
right because again it's relative to the
working directory but wait there's more
a lot of people get confused by this
because if you actually go into the exe
file directory right so when we actually
build this project it obviously outputs
an exe file which is what we end up
running if you try and launch it here
it's not going to work because the
working directory is now no longer what
visual studio says it is when it runs
your actual application the working
directory is not the project directory
anymore it's this actual directory with
the exe file and so that's why people
also get confused they end up not
knowing which directory the assets
should be in should they be in the
directory with the exe file should they
be in the directory with the project
file and so sometimes they decide oh
yeah it has to be both because if i want
to distribute this application i want it
to be alongside the exe file that's
mostly true however if you are just
testing this exe file outside of visual
studio what you can actually do is
create a shortcut of the exe file then
if you go into properties you can modify
this start in parameter right so instead
of this being this actual directory that
contains the exe file you can actually
change it back to be the directory of
the project file and so now if i launch
this shortcut
it's going to set the working directory
to be the same as what visual studio
sets it at so that means that i don't
have to copy any assets because you
definitely want to avoid copying assets
that's i would never do that you have to
keep them in sync some people do like a
post build step which is just it's just
slowing down your build for no reason
don't do that just just run this
shortcut of course if you're packaging
it for distribution that's a different
story one final thing i want to mention
is you can also programmatically check
and set your working directory now since
this project is simple 17 you can
actually use the uh brilliant file
system api which i love and if you uh
actually execute this function sd file
system current path you'll see it takes
no parameters which lets you actually
check what that current working
directory is but then you can also set
it to be something so if you wanted it
to be like some kind of working
directory or whatever you can actually
write code like this and it will
programmatically change your working
directory to something else we use this
in hazel for a number of uh different
kind of scenarios in which we actually
want to allow the application or the
game to set its own asset directory and
stuff like that but the point is that's
also possible right so there are a
number of ways to kind of control where
your files are relative to but uh i hope
you enjoyed this little tutorial maybe
this should have been a standalone video
but anyway working directories that's
how they work i don't want to see any
more absolute parts from any of you
please just just just be aware of this
because it is a little bit of a tricky
thing in the beginning and i was i
definitely struggled with this in the
past especially because i mentioned java
in the beginning and java has this whole
concept of like you know of files being
within the jar file and then that's like
a entirely different story but anyway we
won't touch on that so now that we can
actually potentially run this let's just
go ahead and run it and we'll dive in
and take a look at the code
exception throne
nothing nothing ever works okay well
let's go ahead and fix this because
as usual these code reviews are also not
just reviewing the code but also
hopefully sharing a little bit of how i
debug problems and how i approach things
actually one thing i want to mention is
that like you know a lot of people find
code on github and the code itself might
be decent but they download it and
especially if you're a beginner you kind
of just expect that code to work like
you want to be able to download it hit
f5 it works everything's fine but the
reality is sometimes you just need to
tweak some things right and again
usually it's the fault of the author the
person who puts their code online i mean
sometimes they don't intend people to
you know actually look at their code
they're just doing it for themselves
although they if that were the case they
wouldn't be sending an email to churner
review at gmail.com but anyway the point
is i made a video a while back about the
best way to like learn cpls and get
better at it i'll link it up there if
you want to check it out but my point is
that
in that video i said one of the best
ways to learn c plus more is to actually
look at other people's code like you
need to be doing that but other people's
code doesn't work all the time so
hopefully these little kind of debugging
sessions are a way for you to
kind of get a glimpse of how i approach
these kind of kinds of issues i mean
sometimes there's just no fixing
something
because you're not going to spend like a
days fixing it but in this case it's
probably something trivial i expect i
have no idea so let's take a look at it
and hopefully this will be helpful in
some way so what's the problem i like to
look at the exception if we look at the
output window it says that there's the
axis violation reading location blah
blah blah 3c okay so this is already a
very dodgy memory address right 3c
that's the memory address that's way too
small right memory addresses cannot be
that small memory addresses are usually
quite high so what this tells me is that
probably it's trying to find an offset
from a null memory address now i just
happen to know this but you know let's
let's see how else we can see if that's
a true story or not if i go a little bit
up the call stack um then uh okay well
that was pretty quick so this is
actually null right so we are dealing
with a non-pointer acceleration
structure is null we're trying to call
this intersect acceleration structure
um uh function right but the actual
acceleration structure instance
is null right and if we go up a little
bit further i expect we'll see this ac
should be null or empty i guess it's
like a unique pointer or a shared
pointer that's why it says empty and not
null but the point is this actual if you
look at the raw view then you can see
that we are pointing towards like a null
pointer so ac is null not sure why this
has happened um
one good thing you want to do almost
immediately is actually look at the log
uh and you can see that did pay off
because we can't load files again right
even though we fixed this scene and it
seemed to load the scene fine but it
just can't seem to load anything else
right
so always look at the log in case the
person who's written this code
actually logs like error messages for
file reading and stuff like that
i suspected it was like a missing file
because acceleration structure is
obviously the thing that holds like our
vertices and our triangles so that we
can do ray tracing with them and it's
null right so probably couldn't load the
mesh or something like that so let's go
up a little bit and see why i've already
got so much to say about this code but
let's go a little bit um higher uh let's
see so what do we do we do main we do
render so scene i'm guessing the scene
constructor probably ends up loading all
of these files right so let's take a
look at that
um
load scene we loaded the scene
and then
we do root paths so root path is scene
path and then we find input and we
we
okay so we erase
okay
let's put a breakpoint in here
by the way another reason why it's
important i think to fix projects that
you get from github if you're trying to
learn more about them is because you can
read the code and that's all fine but
being able to actually tweak the code
play with it debug it see how the code
flows by placing breakpoints and then
hitting them and stuff like that that's
a far better way to learn than simply
reading the code right so that's why you
know if you download a project the
code's there great but it doesn't work
that's also a very bad situation to be
in so
yeah anyway so we we find uh we find
input so input shotgun scene is is the
actual
um
this should be like a debugging series
shouldn't it code review more like debug
review or like
anyway whatever so
um man okay so so we erase well in this
case like what are we even raising we
just raise everything
so the root path is nothing
root path don't find input
wait
hold your horses let's go back to this
does it really just wipe that
hold on a minute
hold your
collective horses everyone
okay right so it okay no it doesn't work
i thought what it might do is like just
strip the entire path up until input and
it's like okay that's what you mean but
that's also weird anyway yeah this does
have a root path and then i guess uh it
sets the root path to be that and then
it tries to like it separates the scene
path or something it's all very weird
i'm not sure why it's written this way
to be honest um i think that like the
way that the file system is working in
this project is a little bit over
complicated for not much reason at all
but you try to extract the root path
because you expect an input directory
from there and then also i think from
the console we could also tell that it
looks a little bit weird because
um
like we're trying to load uh
like why is there a leading slash here
that's a bit of a that's a bit bad news
i mean input objects um what do we have
here so like input
objects shotgun yeah like this stuff
seems to exist right there's a shotgun
obj but this leading slash is probably
ruining everything so i'm not sure why
that's happening so let's go back
another great strategy is to actually
like this seems like a uh an actual
string is to just search for strings
that you see printed in the console
because obvious obviously i've never
looked at this code before i don't know
where it is but if i search for that you
can see i i can find it so load bmp
could not open bmp file and then the
file name so let's just place a
breakpoint in this function and work
backwards a little bit so file name is
uh slash okay so there is a leading
slash for some reason i'm gonna try and
track it down so this obviously comes in
from here
and
mesh
oh okay so it tries to do options root
path plus this
and then plus this string value
okay
and what's value
input objects
slash shotgun diffuse
okay so this value here seems okay
right input objects i assume that's
coming from the actual
uh where are we i assume that's coming
from the actual like
shotgun.scene file
right so we have input objects shotgun
all of that stuff that's coming in from
this file however again this whole like
root part situation like i'm not sure
why this is here i think i know why it's
here i think it's because again this
person is trying to load everything in
an absolute fashion because if we think
back to what this used to be right the
root path used to be like the absolute
root of this project so it was like d
drive dev blah blah and then eventually
ray tracing so in that case what they're
doing is they're they obviously have
decided wisely to not store
uh absolute parts inside the scene file
so these are all relative parts but they
think that they need to load
they need to like stitch them up with
the absolute root to then be able to map
this file and load it properly right
which i get that idea but that's just
not true
and in fact again it's much better to
just set a working directory that is not
absolute and then um
kind of see what's going on uh that way
right if you really wanted to stitch
them up for some reason you could also
query to get the current
working directory right so if i wanted
to like
here's what i could do right the correct
fix for this probably would be to just
remove all of this well what i would do
is i would remove all of this options
root path you don't need a root path
right unless again your assets directory
is somewhere else on your computer in
that case you probably will but for this
little ray tracing project i would just
remove this and then you can just
obviously use whatever value you've read
in from that scene file however one
thing you could do is if you really want
a root path um is actually set this road
path to be
std file system current
what was the current directory let me
just include file system
and then we'll see
uh so you could make it i think it's
supposed to be yep current path you
could actually get this and then i guess
as a string assuming this is what you're
storing as a string yeah and so if you
actually do that let's take a look at
what that would give us that would give
us the root path of like that would give
us our working directory right and if
you stitch that up with everything else
um such as where were we trying to load
the bmp file let's hit a five you can
see now we are looking at an actually
real
um
absolute path right so
you could do that um maybe that will
work now yeah it seems to work okay i
assume it's just very slow so let's go
ahead and run it in release mode and
maybe we can like see a frame or
something 71
oh
there we go look at that it even opened
up
the photo view on my computer so we have
a shotgun great i'd like to see that
other kind of reflection scene as well
um but yeah it looks pretty good i guess
um looks like maybe
something like mipmapping could
definitely be
implemented as well as uh anti-aliasing
because that looks pretty uh jaggy but
yeah that's pretty cool so you're
rendering a 3d model looks like there's
a bit of lighting going on as well you
mentioned i think normal maps although
it's kind of hard to see no well no
there is clearly like a lot of bump
going on here
which i assume isn't just from the
albedo map so yeah looks pretty cool in
general opening up in a photo app as
well is pretty nice the final kind of
testing that i will do before we jump in
and take a look at the actual code is i
want to see if there's um
i mean what scene should i run i think
full scene dot scene sounds juicy so
so let's
let's go ahead and try that one out a
little status update i've been sitting
here for about a minute this is this is
taking
this is taking some serious time it'd be
funny if at 100 just like delete
system32 what am i doing with my life
okay finally so we have this result
i don't know why that took so long
because the shotgun looks almost
identical i mean there's a sky box and a
sphere with like some reflection going
on but
that's that's a bit weird look at that
105 seconds like two minutes almost that
took so that's quite a bit anyway let's
finally dive into the code and take a
little bit of a look and i'm going to
see if
i can criticize this to death
i love these things okay so scene scene
path so okay so let's talk about this
right so i don't like this kind of
pattern right if you're making a
variable like this on the stack there's
nothing wrong with it per se but i would
much rather create it like this and then
actually call render on it the reason
being that making a making an object
like this
you're not really giving it like an l
value it's still kind of it's all kind
of in temporary land and then you're
calling dot render on it and like the
scope of this is kind of not really as
easy to define as well as if you wanted
to have other functions that wouldn't
really work there's nothing really bad
with this per se it's not like it's
gonna you know ruin your program but
it's just stylistically not something i
would do i wouldn't create an object on
the stack like this and then call dot
render on it as if it was like some kind
of chained function that's
not really how i would do things i would
create the variable like this and then
call.render on it which
i think gives a little bit more scope to
scene um but also if you're doing if
you're doing stuff like this it's almost
like worthwhile to ask yourself do i
really need to make a class out of this
and do i really need to be like all
object-oriented about this again nothing
specifically bad about that but um you
know this maybe could have just been a
function although i do kind of
understand what you're doing you're
almost creating scene as a context with
an actual file right and then you can
you know use that file to do things with
it but again because you have written it
in one line like this and it this scene
instance doesn't really exist for long
it also doesn't really make sense in a
way if you catch my drift so um
yeah i mean i would totally understand
it if you you know had seen you set the
path that's kind of the context it loads
the file and now you can do many kind of
operations on it like render it multiple
times from different camera angles and
you want it to all revolve around this
context that in my opinion is a good use
for like my hand class out of it
but anyway moving on to the scene which
is where everything begins let me take a
look at what you've got here
um okay so
all right
nothing really too big to draw attention
to here
this is interesting we'll take a look at
this in a minute
the thing that stands out to me
immediately is that everything is public
right so some of this stuff probably
does not need to be public you should
probably hide some of this stuff and
make it private right either that or
just use structs because it looks like
everything here is just all exposed
which is again totally fine
i don't really think that you need to be
necessarily pedantic about private and
public stuff unless you're designing an
api this is clearly just like a little
project um so
not sure if that's even worth drawing
attention to but for everyone watching
you know you'd probably want to uh not
have some of this stuff here one thing i
really like doing that i didn't used to
do in the past i used to also just
declare variables at the top i think i
was coming from java and i was used to
um you know you kind of declare your
variables at the top of the file there
is no header file c plus plus kind of
file in java but
what i do these days is i actually
declare the functions at the top and
then usually i have my private variables
down the bottom i know these are public
variables but same thing almost same
thing so the reason i do this and again
it doesn't might not make sense in this
case because you have made everything
public so everything is kind of
user-facing but usually when you open a
header file right the the first thing
that you care about is what can i do
with this class and usually that does
not involve ah yeah the private members
that i can't even touch right um and i
mean in this case i doubt that you are
going to be you know looking at this
file and being like oh yeah i guess i'll
play with the lights like this directly
right especially if you if you happen to
like have functions for setting lights
or whatever so my point being that it's
nice to be able to look at a class and
the first thing you see is the api what
can i do with this class you know how do
i call the constructor what parameters
what parameters does it take that kind
of stuff right that's why i like to
reorganize stuff um like that again i'm
just using you as an example here
because obviously
everything's public so technically
everything is user-facing and therefore
maybe you would like to see this but i
still maintain that the constructor is
usually the first thing you want to look
at when you're dealing with um like a
class like this unless it's like a
structure of data and the constructor is
there for convenience
uh camera you've got here okay this
looks like okay so you've made your own
little math library that's interesting
um that's kind of cool
uh let me just quickly
uh breeze through this okay so you've
got matrix 4x4 okay so basically
everything you need for ray tracing it
looks like you've pretty much got that
stuff here now a word of advice to
people doing this kind of stuff
i probably wouldn't write my own math
library right unless this was like the
first time i've ever done any like
graphics programming or mathematics and
i really just wanted the experience of
actually writing that stuff myself to
learn more about it that is totally okay
and in fact i probably encourage that
but for the most part right i am going
to assume that this specific project is
about ray tracing right if you want to
learn about ray tracing you don't need
to write your own math library you
definitely need to understand the
mathematics behind it right but you
don't need to like i wouldn't waste time
making
a math library basically is my point
right unless as i mentioned earlier you
really want to because you've never done
it before and you're interested in how
math libraries work and your kind of
this project is not just about ray
tracing but from now on i'm going to
assume this project is just about ray
tracing so in that case i wouldn't use i
i would i wouldn't write my own math
library i would definitely use something
like glm now the reason is twofold first
of all it's a tremendous waste of time
in my opinion to implement all of these
functions make sure they work with
different types and all of that stuff
right
because
it's much better to just learn the
theory of how to use these functions if
that makes sense the implementation is
not really that important the second
reason though possibly more important is
that uh this is going to be much slower
than something like glm because this
does not use any ssc instructions right
so sse is a way for you to be able to
kind of execute uh you know certain
certain mathematical operations like
multiplication between matrices and
between vectors and stuff like that
a lot faster because what you can
actually do is load up these special
registers on your cpu like a 128 bit
wide register which holds four floats
you can load them up with data and then
execute that kind of multiplication
operation in a single instruction rather
than rather than four instructions right
for each float so that tremendously
speeds up stuff and something like glm
obviously implements ssc right they've
written their math library with ssa
support it's also called neon on arm
architectures so the point being that
like you know unless you're gonna learn
that which actually is something useful
i think to learn to just be aware of how
ssc works and
i mean a lot of people don't even know
that it exists so it's really
it it is definitely very educational but
my point is that you know instead of
spending time on this you could have
spent time learning a little bit more
about ray tracing in fact i think the
topic of ray tracing is something that
pretty much every c plus programmer
should touch at some point there's like
this ray tracing in one weekend thing um
it's like a little book slash website uh
definitely recommend you guys check that
out if you haven't already it's it's a
fantastic exercise um it's actually
something i wanted to make as like a
little video series on youtube just
basically implementing that ray tracing
in one weekend thing and talking about
everything and maybe how we can speed it
up and stuff like that let me know if
you're interested in that but that was
an idea i had a while ago but yeah so
those are kind of my thoughts on
the idea of making a math library again
not that i'm 100 against that i just
think that um
in the in the long term it's probably
not something you generally want to do
so let's dive into the scene constructor
and see how this works so this dot loads
it okay so this is like another thing
right you don't need to use the this
pointer right the only reason you would
ever use this pointer really like this
is if you had like you know you had a
member variable called the same name and
a local variable called c name and you
want to specifically reference like the
uh
the member variable right then you would
have to use this if they have the same
name again in my experience you wouldn't
have the same name because you would use
like a convention like m underscore and
that would kind of fix that as well as
you'll be aware of your member variables
versus local variables um but and
obviously the other use case is if you
actually want like a pointer to the
current instance for whatever reason
then of course you'll need to use this
or const if it's in a const function
right that's pretty uh that's pretty
pretty standard but otherwise there's
just no reason to use that right just
call the load scene function like this
okay so if enable output then we output
stuff
uh okay cool road path blah blah blah um
okay and then
and then you do a lot of
okay a few things here um so you
basically do a lot of parsing that kind
of what looks to be a custom
file another thing that i probably
wouldn't do right again unless you want
to learn about parsing and learn about
how to make your own file format which
is totally
totally legit nothing wrong with that
but again if your purpose is ray tracing
um
i would focus on that instead and you
could use a well-defined format like
json or yaml i would use yaml for this
because a little bit more human readable
no like square brackets and curly
brackets everywhere to keep track of and
commas you know yaml is really quite
nice for like human readability and for
a human to edit right so that's what i
would do instead of doing this stuff
because you could use a library for that
you wouldn't have to write the parsing
code yourself and also it's just a more
robust file format that can support a
lot more things um you know like looking
at this like i don't know is our space
is implemented what if a space isn't and
then i want to write this in quotes does
your code handle quotes like there's a
lot of kind of problems with custom file
formats obviously and a lot of little
things that you might not take into
account um so in the in the general case
for most people i would just use
something like yaml
the other thing that's kind of
that's kind of uh standing out to me
let's say is this kind of log error
thing
right so log error is obviously a macro
that you've got going on here
and
like it's a little bit
okay so so let's talk about this right
so the reason you're using a macro here
probably is because you want to use
these kind of preprocessor variables
right you want to know what file's
coming from what the function name is
and then also the line number right that
that's totally legit but the thing is i
would write this a little bit
differently what you're doing here is
you're kind of breaking c syntax and
it's actually causing some problems so
what i mean by that is you know because
the preprocessor is literally just
something that copies and pastes stuff
right before we send it to the compiler
it means that we can really
define things that break the c plus kind
of syntax and style and stuff like that
so a good example is if i wanted to you
know i could create a little begin and
end keyword if i wanted to be more like
some other language that has that i
think pascal has something similar um
but if i wanted to basically do that i
could write code like this
right and that would be totally fine it
will compile it will work but the reason
i don't do that is because it kind of
breaks c plus plus syntax right like if
we're reading c plus plus code we want
to kind of be in the loop with c plus we
don't want to do something that
completely
changes the language usually right and
so that's what i don't like about this
function or this macro right what i
would do instead is i would add
some parentheses and i would get rid of
the semicolon it's a very very small
kind of
um
[Music]
change right but what that would mean is
that instead of writing code like this
right you would actually need to write
code like that and now that looks like
an actual function call and that makes
sense even though it it's a macro you
can see my syntax highlighter is saying
there's a macro because it's purple but
also it's in all caps and usually if
something is capitalized we we usually
use that convention for macros right we
wouldn't have a function uh you know
with this kind of naming convention or
this kind of naming
naming style i guess but anyway so
that's what i would do the other problem
though with the with what you've done
here which is not very good at all is
what it looks like is that if this is
the case your return result and then it
looks like you return well nothing at
all if if there was no error like this
whole thing in this weird indentation
which i can see you don't have here but
this just looks bizarre right because
again it's kind of tricking you it's
almost saying that like well if that
happens log error but really the purpose
of this if statement is to execute this
which again then results in no return no
variables being returned what's actually
happening here though because you of
course do have a semicolon at the end of
this macro what really is happening here
is it's actually just doing this and
then it's returning all the time right i
mean look even like even my even visual
studios can like confuse us to the
indentation of this because there's no
semicolon here and i guess it doesn't
really properly evaluate that
preprocessor so it's it's all a little
bit weird and it breaks c plus syntax a
little bit so what i would do instead is
first of all never write one line if
statements maybe with the exception of
if you have a conversion function and
it's like if the string equals blah blah
blah return this enum value you know for
stuff like that i do tend to put it onto
one line because more or less a
conversion function but for actual code
flow functions like this put them on two
lines like this right just do this right
um why okay let's talk about why so
first of all
the re like the biggest reason why i
like this apart from readability so i in
my opinion this is easier to read right
but obviously that's an opinion but in
terms of um why i would actually do this
i think that the biggest reason is
probably debug ability right so the
problem with having every having your
if7 on one line is that if i put a
breakpoint here
what happens
well it's going to break when it hits
this if statement
and then also if it hits the result or
not so so at a glance as i'm debugging i
don't know if this evaluates to true or
false right if it is like this very easy
to see if i hit f10 once this breakpoint
has been hit it's going to jump to this
it's not going to jump into here so that
already makes it easier the other really
good debugging
thing that this allows you to do is
actually specifically break on errors
right so again if this was all on one
line like this then i i'm going to break
on every call of this if statement which
is useless to me because i want to break
only on the error this lets me put a
break point on this line and then only
detect errors and then be in a state
where i can debug why that was an error
does that make sense so that's what i
would do instead of um you know putting
if segments on one line because it gives
me that ability to kind of debug my code
a lot easier and i also personally just
think that it does in fact to look a
little bit more readable now i actually
used to do one line of statements like
this when i back up like 10 years ago
when i used to program in java but since
then i've definitely switched to this
because i think it's just it's just a
lot easier to deal with um so yeah so
that's my kind of speech about your use
of macros and also if statements uh and
hopefully you can see kind of why that's
a problem why i wouldn't do it this way
so that's all the whole parsing thing
let's actually dive into some of the ray
tracing code um and we will uh
we will we'll we will get on with this
the general structure of this code as i
glance through it it's pretty good like
i don't really have many issues with it
there are some stylistic changes that i
would you know i write my code
differently like i would use um
uh curly brackets i would open them up
on a separate line again when i used to
write code in java i did used to do it
on the same line
but since uh working with cpos plus and
a little bit more in the professional
industry i think this is much more
readable um so that's what i would do
especially because it is more or less
like a c c plus kind of convention
and usually i end up writing code uh
usually not always but i end up kind of
matching my convention with whatever
language whatever the main convention
kind of or the main kind of uh style is
for a language
um okay so let's surrender work let's
kind of uh where's the actual render
function right because i remember that
that was something that was called from
the main function so render okay so i've
seen load success return negative one
okay you're returning negative one but
then you're not handling that so that's
also something that maybe you could
print an error or like i'm not sure
handle that also long long like bro
we're way past that
you're specifically using c plus or 17.
that's what you said right so you are
way past that
stop using int stop using well you can
use end fine i'll i'll let you use int
but long long i don't want to see that
man if you wanted something to be a long
long use in 64 t right or you went for
unsigned long long right start using
these types and stop using the kind of
built-in types right because these
obviously the biggest the biggest
difference here is that these have a
size in the name
8 bits 16 bits 32 bits 64 bits right we
know how big these are they are
guaranteed to be that size on whatever
compiler on whatever platform you're
working with
this useless pile of garbage has
absolutely no information about how big
it is right along on linux is not the
same as a long on
on windows along the windows typically
is 32 bits right a long long is 64 bits
which is why you see this defined that's
different on other platforms so it's
just it's really just annoying right so
just use these as much as you can ins
i don't in my experience it's like
always 32 bits i'm sure there's probably
not
but i've never seen in b not 32 bits or
not four bytes
but so that's it therefore like i i do
use int from time to time but i think if
you want to be pedantic about it you
should just use these types for all of
your integer needs and that's it um so
that's what i would do i would not use
long long right that's uh definitely not
a good idea so
uh
we have a frame but okay options high
width so this is our main frame buffer
this is that pixel array i was talking
about vect3 so we have like an rgba
sorry not rgba just rgb kind of float
array of color values in here which is
what we end up outputting to that bmp
file oh how are you outputting the bmp
file save image
ah cool yeah that's what i thought so
bmp is actually a really easy file
format to work with to the point where
you don't need a library really to kind
of
you know write bmp files or read bmp
files you can see there's just a little
header here which you uh basically so
you have this header uh with a header
size of 54 bytes that you kind of
allocate here
on the stack and then you particular
offsets write in data which is what we
what we do for the bmp file format and
then you obviously uh basically copy
across all those pixel values into that
um into that buffer which is pretty cool
right so it's really easy to do this
that's again something i expected you to
do just because you also made your own
math library and all that stuff so
that's cool it's nice to see stuff like
this teaches you a lot about it so i'm
beginning to think this is more of like
a general purpose educational
programming thing and not specifically
about ray tracing uh but that's cool um
and then what are you doing here shell
execute open okay so this is the code
that actually opens up whatever your
default windows app is for um looking at
uh image files which is why it opened up
photos on my computer and actually
showed me that resulting result of the
ray tracing so that's pretty cool
that's kind of just just a little hunch
i had okay so anyway um so where is that
render function i keep losing it okay
here we go
show ac to show ac we need to go another
routine what is show ac
use ac
show ac user okay well set to
it's set to zero
okay or bro like balls don't set them to
one and zero set them to true and false
like what's going on there come on um
yeah that's interesting well we didn't
do this so we won't
do this but maybe this is like some
somehow it
i don't know what this does i mean like
i'm like in regards to what this does
compared to this but anyway launch
workers is what happens launch workers
so if debug render work in debug mode
would not create any additional threats
oh man
okay so why why is this okay i i okay
where do i start with this i would not
do this um
for a number of reasons first of all
i i really don't understand why you
would not multi-thread this in debug
like that doesn't make any sense to me
if you really wanted to have a single
threading mode well just have like you
know if single threaded then whatever
right that makes a lot more sense or you
could even have it as like a runtime
variable um not necessarily not you
don't need to make it like a
preprocessor thing and then recompile
your code if you want to switch between
the two modes but my point is um so
first of all debug exhaust is already
slow especially for stuff like cpu side
ray tracing debug is a lot slower on the
math side of things right um so because
of that
you're already kind of shooting yourself
on the foot with trying to
get any kind of good performance i mean
i know you're more about like seconds
per frame here instead of frames per
second but my point is that it's that's
why i couldn't even run it in debug mode
i had to switch to release immediately
which presents another problem what if i
have an issue that i'm trying to debug
well i have to what sit through like you
know five hours of waiting for stuff to
render before i finally hit my break
point on like this in this in this kind
of lighting pass or whatever this
reflection pass iteration or whatever
you know when i'm tracing that ray and i
want to debug it like that's it just
makes debugging a lot harder also what
if i'm having multi-threading issues
what if i'm having things that are weird
race conditions that i want to maybe
debug by putting a breakpoint in and
seeing what thread ends up calling that
like it it just it's just a bit of a
mess right and i can't do that because
apparently i only multi-thread and
release so that's a bit weird to me like
i definitely wouldn't do this um try and
keep your code more or less the same in
debug and release unless of course
there's extra code like error checking
that you want to do only in debug that's
totally valid but changing the whole
architecture of everything between debug
and release is a bit weird um
so i definitely wouldn't do that
um so so okay so this calls okay so it
ultimately does the same thing right so
zero and what does this function take
uh frame buffer uh y zero y one so
that's okay
okay i see right
okay
so you've split the
i guess you've split it into vertical
strips
how many threads do we have eight
jokes on you i have 16 cores and 32
threads but anyway um so
we've split it up into eight threads and
they're working on these kind of
vertical slices of the image right so
this is actually kind of similar to what
we looked at last time with the voxel
engine however it's obviously doing ray
tracing instead um although i guess
maybe the voxel thing could be perceived
as some form of ray tracing maybe well
it's more great casting i guess but
anyway whatever um so
uh that's what we're doing here right uh
as opposed to this in which we go from
zero to height right so we go from oh
maybe we're doing horizontals no we're
probably doing horizontal slices i don't
know why i thought vertical slices um
from zero to height yeah yeah we're
doing horizontal which is better anyway
you usually want to do that um tiles
would also be interesting
but anyway so
we go all the way from zero to height in
a single pass versus splitting it up
into eight different sections and
working on them simultaneously which is
what the purpose of kind of
multi-threading this is i guess
so
um again
wouldn't do that i would definitely run
it multithreaded in both debug and
release let's dive into this a little
bit okay so you have a thread pull which
is cool
you have a thread pull of unique pointer
threads which you're creating here
again no reason to do that right um
instead of doing this
i would make a thread pull of just
threads because i don't really see why
you would want them to be unique
pointers right so unique pointers um
obviously can't be copied same as
threads i'm pretty sure the thread
copy constructor
is disabled so let's just say okay so
let's just say i did this
let's actually move this down
yeah so what i would do ultimately is
have a thread pull let's call this
churno pool um that's like like this
right and then um so if i try and copy
this
uh to
here i'm assuming
yeah so that won't work because the copy
constructor has been deleted but i can
still move it
just
yeah thanks bro just just like as what's
happening here you can't copy you can't
copy unique pointers but you can move
them into this vector which is what's
going on here um in fact we can see that
it's specifically the move the r value
reference version of pushback that's
being used here right so in terms of
like copying and moving stuff around you
can do whatever you can you can do
whatever you want with thread um
as with unique pointers right but also i
yeah i just don't see any reason why you
would ever use unique pointers here i
mean you only have eight instances of
them so it's not like the heap
allocation cost
um
is gonna be like something that you'll
even see
but i just think that like it's in
general it's good to get into the
practice of just not heap allocating
whenever you can
avoid it right so just try and allocate
stuff on the stack as much as you can
unless there's a specific reason why you
need why you need it to be on the heap
right um a lot of people see unique
pointers and smart pointers as a way
that obviously they hide that new kind
of call and so it looks like maybe it's
not as scary or not as bad but
obviously they're still calling you i
would definitely um just make a vector
of threads like this
so um
yeah so that's the only thing here but
it's good that you're you know you're
not creating these every frame i mean
you don't have the concept of frames you
just launch this and you finish your
render and then that's it the
application terminates um so
yeah but in general it's nice to have a
thread pull which you then wait for
every thread to join obviously so you
wait for every thread to complete the
rendering before you actually bounce
back to this code and return zero so
that's fine um
the fingerprint is a load so what's this
okay so you're using atomic variables
for
statistics so i'm assuming each of these
workers when they finish they
write
um okay so i wouldn't use load right i
would just use with atomic variables you
can just use them as normal variables
like as if they were just
that right so there's no real reason to
use load there are technically some
differences between load and not using
load but in this case you're not going
to see any difference so i would
definitely write the code just like that
because it's just a little bit easier to
read you don't need the load function
everywhere
but other than that like
good you know um obviously you don't
want a case in which you uh try to try
to write to one of these variables
simultaneously so atomic is is a good
fix for that
um
and then okay i see so this is just this
is basically just you on the main thread
if apple progress is set to true um
you're basically
you just have this like a loop that
basically prints
how long does it sleep for like 10
milliseconds in this case
okay whatever um you just have this like
little loop here that basically at a
fixed time interval it looks like um it
just outputs the percentage of that's
what we saw that's where we saw the
percentage being output like when i said
94 whatever um that's happening here so
on the main thread again which is you
don't need to like lock this uh
logging log log lock you don't need to
log log um because uh we're on the main
thread we're only printing stuff from
the main thread um for anyone else there
who might be multithreading stuff just
remember if you are printing from
multiple threads
like see out isn't thread safe so you
want to probably have a lock have a log
function and then have it like a little
spin lock that you um basically lock the
that function so that you can't call it
for multiple threads at once because
then you'll get
stuff printing in the middle of other
stuff and yeah
so but but doesn't apply here because
we're only doing the printing on the
main thread which is cool so this is a
nice little system and then we join so
finally last thing we'll look at today
this is a very long video um
but i don't know i'm just this is just
what i'm doing
this is just me
that's just what i happen to be doing
today looking at this for an hour um so
render worker so we get a frame buffer
um we have this like you know
kind of region here on the y-axis that
we've decided to render to and then i'm
assuming yeah we do like class ray we
get away from the camera based on where
we um which pixel i guess we're working
on um
and then we do
so again you know multiple line i would
drop your little uh if statements here
especially if you seem to be doing it
sometimes
we have a little show normals thing
which is cool um i mean again i'm not
really going to get into like the
algorithm of ray tracing if you guys are
interested in that then i'll leave a
link in the description to the ray
tracing in one weekend thing um because
that's that's definitely a good read
and it's probably good for everyone to
read but um
yeah i mean this just looks like pretty
typical so you've got area lights so
area lights and these are all kind of
pointers because i think that's probably
okay so you have a light hierarchy um
kind of like i guess what you that's why
i saw that object pointer as well i
guess object is also a base class for a
lot of things like triangles meshes and
spheres and stuff like that i assume
yeah there's sphere
okay i mean that's reasonable i don't
know if i would hierarchically kind of
structure it
um with inheritance and stuff like that
if i was doing it it's just a stylistic
thing no real reason not to i guess um
and i'm assuming that these things do in
fact have different functions like set
points and illuminate what does that do
nothing uh
yeah i think one thing that i probably
wouldn't do as well is
have these functions like you know
directional or distant light distant
light interesting
definitely it looks like a directional
light although it does have a point
that is unused
um yeah i i guess i get why you're doing
that it's because lots of different
types and you have a different
illuminate function for each but i think
i would try as much as possible to
contain the algorithm within like
the function right i think the only real
reason that you would want to
maybe bring stuff out into functions is
if you want to
like specifically avoid code duplication
that's
very valid and that's where you would do
that like you don't want to be copying
pasting the same code multiple times but
changing parameters that's what
functions are for
but
you know sometimes people tend to break
stuff up into functions or into classes
for no reason and it actually makes
stuff harder to read because instead of
looking at this screen like i am right
now and seeing the whole algorithm i
have to jump to this function and then
be like ah but what light type is it you
know what i mean it just makes stuff a
little bit harder to read um so that's
why like i i would maybe avoid that not
to mention that if it's a it'll be a
virtual function call here which isn't a
big deal but potentially worth
being aware about
um so i would try as much as possible to
just contain the algorithm within this
function or again with code duplication
you know maybe bring it out into
other sub functions that are also kind
of in this file and i'll call this file
like renderer.cpp so that's probably
what i would do if i was doing this
uh maybe i will when i do that ray
tracing in one weekend video series but
um yeah
other than that like yeah you've just
got some kind of basic like rendering
equations here there's nothing too like
complicated with this i think
um not nothing i can see from the code
nothing i can see from the result really
you're just basically shooting out
racing what they hit mathematically what
they intersect what the color should be
based on the material on the surface and
stuff like that reflecting rays and
refracting them for certain glass types
i guess because i i think i saw refract
yeah refract computer refraction and
this is for like transparent material so
if you've got like glass so yeah so
overall um yeah pretty cool little
project uh definitely a lot of things i
would probably uh change if it was me
writing it as well as i would definitely
um try and kind of make it real time i'm
more of a real-time rendering programmer
but i do still love ray tracing and i
think that you could definitely start to
maybe move this stuff into like a
compute shader or even keep it cpu but
kind of um make an application out of it
that you can actually see the result
with and play around with like where the
camera is and stuff like that um that's
where i would probably take this next if
you were serious about kind of making a
ray tracing engine because that's
obviously something that's um possible
to do and also i think a lot of fun but
generally i don't have that much like i
mean apart from what i've said i like
the structure of your project actually
one thing that um kind of caught my eye
when i glanced at like the source
directory is like you've only got five
cpp files and like they're pretty big
like well they're not that big but
kilobytes 25 kilobytes like this is good
you know a lot of code that i look at
has
three times the number of files and
they're all like two or one kilobyte
right that's really annoying for me to
look at and i
i don't like that like i think i
remember back when i worked at ea
um i looked at frostbite and i'm pretty
sure
that
like the entire directx
11 i think renderer that frostbite had
like all of the api calls to directx 11
at least back in the day
they were all in one file like there was
just a file called dx11 or dx12 or
whatever and
they were just all there like literally
the whole the whole render it's like 20
000 lines or something like that the
whole kind of back end for that api
was in a single file and i looked at
that i'm like man this is amazing i i
thought i would have to spend like hours
looking through the whole code base and
you don't want to look through the whole
code base man there's like 250 projects
in the visual studio solution i think
something like that like you don't want
to look at the whole like it's a there's
a lot it's very complex right but seeing
that was like it was almost like a light
a light shining from above that was just
like it's all here man you just look at
the whole thing here like you don't have
to
you don't have to open more than one
file literally like it's amazing so i
really like that i really like that
approach to software
again sometimes you could argue it
doesn't make sense i agree i'm not
saying you should have main.cpp and that
is the end of that i'm saying that
trying to minimize separating all of
that stuff out
um and abstracting stuff in like an oop
way which is what so many people love to
do
right i think that dramatically helps
pretty much everything anyway i hope you
guys enjoyed this video please don't
forget to hit the like button if you did
uh churno review gmail.com is in the
description and that is the email
address where you can send me your
project if you guys have any suggestions
for projects that you want me to look at
i've been looking at a lot of like
rendering related stuff this is this is
stuff i'm naturally interested in i mean
we haven't looked at ray tracing before
but like if there's something specific
that you want me to take a look at i
know you don't really know what emails i
received but still if there's a topic
just write a comment below send in that
email with whatever project you um you
have and you want me to take a look at
don't forget to check out skillshare
using the link in the description below
and i will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you